hey guys it's Monday august 3rd and i'm
your host to marry Kish Jess McDonald is
taking a week off and Chris waters is
missing presumably dead if anyone has
any information on his whereabouts
please let me know for the rest this
week I will be your host let's do it
first up we have what we call a news
sandwich where I say something good and
then something bad and then I'm done
something good so it doesn't suck so bad
alright let's do it the phantom pain on
PC is coming out sooner than expected
multiplayer won't be available at launch
and pre-orders come with ground zeroes
the game's release date has been moved
up from September 15th to September
first to match the console release date
the Japanese publisher also announced
today that everyone who pre-orders the
phantom pain on steam will receive the
2014 prologue ground zeroes for free on
top of that everyone who buys the PC
Edition not just pre-orders it will
receive a behind-the-scenes collectors
video and documentary they'll also get a
venom snake emblem and something called
the mother base staff dlc fans are
hoping to play competitive multiplayer
in Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain
will have to wait a few weeks after the
game's launch developer Konami announced
that Metal Gear Online will be released
on october sixth on consoles and
sometime in january 2016 for pc metal
gear solid 5 the phantom pain is coming
to xbox one 360 ps4 ps3 and pc on
September first next up have you ever
had that eerie feeling like you're being
watched
well if you work at Konami that's just a
normal day because the new report is
showing that the employees are being
monitored with surveillance cameras
publisher konami has come under fire
again after a japanese newspaper
published a report which showed in
detail how employees are being treated
the report stated Kojima production
staff are restricted from accessing
internet while at work lunch breaks are
managed with time cards and employees
that do not adhere to prescribe break
times are named and shamed according to
the report the working status of
employees is monitored through the use
of cameras employees who do not perform
to expectations could be transferred to
other tasks such as assembly work
security guard duty or even cleaning the
gym need for speed is fast the series
producer has been saying it might be
even too fast possibly even too furious
between 2002 and 2013 at least one Need
for Speed game came out every year in
2011 publisher EA actually launched to
need for speed games shift 2 unleashed
and the run but the publisher and
developer ghost games took the last year
off and now they're working on a reboot
of the series in a new interview
executive producer Marcus Nilsson
explained this move by stating that was
simply too many need for speed games
released too quickly Nielsen States was
it confusing to have need for speed the
run after shift to absolutely not only
does it saturate need for speed but it
also confuses you to fix this problem EA
and ghost games waited a year and
essentially restart at the series taking
the year off is obviously an answer to
that he said we used it to figure out
who we are and what we should be this
reboot of the franchise is about getting
the foundation correctly laid out what
you see here is what the need for speed
experience will be for the foreseeable
future the need for speed reboot
launches on November third for xbox one
playstation 4 and pc when fallout 4
comes out you're going to want to break
out your sweatpants stock up on soda say
goodbye to your loved ones because you
might be playing it 400 hours there was
never much doubt that fallout 4 would be
an absolutely massive game that will
surely end up taking a lot of your time
but now the game's lead producers jeff
gardner said I've played the game for
probably 400 hours and I'm
still finding stuff I haven't seen
Gardner went on to say that this is
partly the result of the games crafting
system which sounds fairly extensive and
intricate he also talked about how
players will need to scavenge for very
specific items fallout 4 launches on
November 10th for xbox one playstation 4
MPC well that's it for today but i'll be
back again tomorrow with more news most
likely gamescom related but to know for
sure you'll have to see me then on
gamespot com